[Applaudissements]
bonjour Juliette ça va ça va très bien
et vous même super bien
Amélie
net Armanet et Amélie Bonnard
réalisatrice de partir un jour nommé ce
soir au César raconte-nous un petit peu
le l'histoire du film pour ceux qui
l'auraient pas vu l'histoire du
court-métrage alors je te laisse
raconter bien sûr l'histoire du film
l'histoire du film c'est l'histoire d'un
jeune homme qui revient dans le village
où il a grandi où il est pas revenu
depuis des années et qui retombe sur son
amour d'adolescence et qui se demande
qu'est-ce qui serait passé s'il avait
pris un autre chemin et Juliette vous
vous êtes dedans vous êtes actrice
dedans avec Bastien bouillon qui est
nommé ce soir
rôle au cinéma et c'est grâce à Amélie
toute cette histoire de fou en fait
voilà et racontez-moi maintenant vous
allez être actrice aussi je sais pas on
verra en tout cas
ça donne envie en tout cas ce qui m'a
donné envie c'est d'avoir une si belle
équipe de travailler avec des gens parce
que l'économie des courts-métrages elle
est précaire et donc d'avoir senti la
foi la passion la fougue autour de
autour du cinéma comme ça ça donne très
envie en tout cas d'une aventure
collective
bah oui oui c'est une comédienne ouais
mais c'est aussi c'est aussi une très
grande chanteuse on va vous entendre en
direct sur Canal le 17
Marsa maintenant ce sera le concert que
je donne d'habitude qui sera retransmis
en direct sur Canal à Bercy le 17 mars
venez nombreux voilà
je vous le conseille merci beaucoup et
je vous dis un gros pour ce soir bonne
soirée merci